there's a song called she will be loved
the day that we wrote it we thought
towards those Wow like this song is
gonna mean a lot to a lot of people we
just kind of had that feeling or I guess
it was just one of those like special
moments where I thought wow you know
we're gonna have a career because of
this song I didn't know that I'd be
right about it but I felt that way about
it was one of those premonitions I
thought wow this song is the key to
reach millions and millions of people
and I think it's really gonna be special
it's actually a song that I wrote about
a girl and a guy that I knew who just
have a very like tumultuous kind of
troubled relationship I was looking at
it from an outside perspective she was
not like good place and he was he's a
really nice person and he kind of like
was very nurturing to her and supportive
of her it was one of the fastest song he
ever wrote
just boom sat down scribbled some words
on paper recorded the song it was done
like in an hour
that's why I was so excited because it
happened really fast and I just
instantaneously I just knew I was like
oh my god this is it was lightning in a
bottle I liked writing those words about
you know someone's being alone in their
car and it kind of creates a really cool
visual picture
[Music]
that was to me one of my favorite songs
that did I wrote it and I know it was
definitely catapulted the band to a
different place
[Music]
[Music]
you